I'm with first we feast and we got
Michael Ian Black here you might know
him from stand-up and sketch comedy the
movie wet hot American summer and most
recently we found out he's a huge
ice-cream fan maybe even a fiend he's
got these new ads for Klondike candy
bars what a banana candy is the banana
necessary these new ads have a bit of a
racy theme to him he talked about that
well the idea was you know Klondike
arenas Klondike the classic delicious
ice cream bar and then you got just
candy the classic genre of food and
somebody at Klondike said hey what if we
mated those two things right right so
I'm telling the story of how Klondike
and candy King now you're a parent don't
you think you have a little
responsibility you have to teach youth
about ice cream
absolutely responsibility my kids are
learning about not only human anatomy
but ice cream Anatomy through these ads
look if somebody's going to teach my
kids about sex it may as well be an ice
cream company I know for me
given the choice between ice cream and
lovemaking probably choose ice cream and
then maybe lovemaking after or even
better the ice cream sandwich the ice
cream sandwich which is ice cream
lovemaking and my screen now do you
think you might be also sort of
suggesting some kind of some weird stuff
a union between two food groups yeah I
don't normally go together yes that's
exactly what we're suggesting are you
worried that other foods might start
mating like like hotdogs and Gatorade
yeah I would stay away from using hot
dogs as an analogy in this particular
conversation good I see you're sharp
today what's next in comedy are you just
gonna stick only to ice cream no I would
love to be able to pursue a full-time
career in ice cream but I'm traveling
all over the country telling jokes it
would be great if Klondike would sponsor
my tour you ready to do a taste test so
let's pretend we're on a first date and
it's going well and because I'm trying
to impress her I eat it as seductively
as I can so it might look something like
this
okay and now kids this dates not going
so well
well I mean you think like Oh Michael
Ian Black he's just some jerk shilling
klondike each other like them we just
said that outside as it happens I really
like these things they're good I'm gonna
have a second bite even though you
didn't ask me to but I don't think you
can go wrong putting a little candy with
some ice cream that's delicious
uh-huh see there's the second bite
good job
you